yeah but usually when you talk about top
5 you I don't want to say you must put
them in position usually each other on
top of five guys are in position so the
fact that you had three centers in your
top five it gave people say you know
chance to say well what about Kobe what
about LeBron I don't have a problem with
journalist I have a problem with
journalists Jeff you ain't got me in the
top ten whatever you smoking down in
Reno you need Jack is not in your top
ten what have you ever seen now up there
Jack I'm not blowing smoke because he's
here when have you ever seen anyone like
Shaq I've never seen anybody like Shaq
ever jack is the most dominant big man
ever in my opinion but okay I put him
behind magic and bird LeBron and Kobe I
didn't put it behind nobody like crazy
like no you didn't even say you did not
say no I'm saying Shaq is right there 11
12 13
oh [ __ ] check you can if you get though
you know one time Jack and I battery
autumn we let's say you're Chuck yes
good listen every time you put Shaquille
O'Neal next to one not three four five
one great player he won a championship